the reason this flowchart is so big in
the first place is because the whole
point is when you've got stationary
points you have to make a choice now
that you know about the first period and
the second derivative you can choose
which one to use and one is sometimes
better than the other and that's what
this box is here in the middle for okay
why would we try to use the second
derivative and the answer is if you get
a function like the ones we've been
having a look at if they're easy to
differentiate then you can avoid doing a
table of values to remember that if you
get a derivative and you pop it in right
and you're like oh it's positive done
you've got a minimum or it's negative
done it's a maximum no table of values
required
I don't like tables of values your time
consume you I'm going to draw stuff I
got to put in lots of substitutions and
all the rest if I can avoid them I will
okay but sometimes you don't want to
differentiate again right if your
function looks for example like this I'm
just gonna give you the example maybe
you wanna draw this I write this with me
have a look at this function right um I
don't want to differentiate this again
can anyone tell me why what what rule do
you have to use to differentiate this
you must use the question rule cuz it's
a question and then him because this
like gobbled mess you like uh you know
once this is the first this is the first
derivative right I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do vu - here's V u - - u V - all over V
squared
I'll go simplify that and then I have to
differentiate again to get to the second
derivative I want to avoid that at all
costs right so basically I'm gonna say
don't differentiate again just use the
first view if you already got it just go
with it
okay so what's my question let me get
this guy out of the way cuz it's gross
my question is is your function easy to
differentiate
if your function is easy to
differentiate then then do it
differentiate again use the second
derivative and then off you go okay if
on the other hand like this example I've
just given you and quotients are the
most common example of this if you look
at it you're like I really don't want to
differentiate that again it is not easy
to differentiate then don't
differentiate again do a table of values
even though tables of value take time it
will still be faster than going through
a second derivative that says no okay so
this is the main thing that guides you
towards one or the other is it easy to
differentiate then do it if it's not
easier to differentiate then don't use
the derivative you've already got okay